[Applause]
irving
fires from straight away kyrie irving
that was such a big moment in there
you're the top
one of the top picks in this game you
get an easy dunk
poster welcome to the league here's
durant
yes great ball rebounded by joe harris
nice move by durant yes again for
kevin durant jordan got back in the
paint and said if you're gonna make that
okay but we're not gonna give up
penetration
harris set the pick durant
again i imagine that this is what it was
like to watch
george gervais east they were swept in
the first round by
toronto 4-0
harris able to retrieve it wide open
shot here
yes deadwood he pops it back the other
way
durant with the step tell you what and
many feel like um
that phoenix team with that staff and
the one before with nash could have won
a championship very easily and so
they got the band back together
opening night in the nba first of our
double header we have the lakers and
clippers coming up in the second game
there's kyrie from deep yes pumped them
up and to be
a cheerleader shut up pass them the ball
tell them to shoot it each time
build their confidence carried out two
for four or seven
that's what levert oh look out off the
off the head of jared allen and irving
takes advantage right there two bad
turnovers by the warriors and obrez bit
off
two of eight from the field
kyrie with the spin kyrie with the
bucket
like coach steve kerr he's going to find
ways to make you better and right there
quick play quick drive to the basket
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it is and i've talked to
coaches my whole career
they hated wearing the suits because
they never wear a suit except game day
and
and they're in the fray too i say listen
we're playing we
we need to be comfortable what do you do
when someone can score off the triple
threat
and hit shots with this type of
difficulty
and tell you what you do you just stick
to your tenants and make sure that you
try to play
some 15 teams because a lot of teams
need you to be in that locker room
curry now 16 point oh a deep three
nets if led by as many as 21.
[Music]
kyrie irving showing the entire
repertoire for 24 points kevin durant
with 12
steph curry 16 14 for 24
kyrie 9 for 13 and durant 5 of 11
from the field
trying to set up irving with the ball
knocked away
here's dinwoody two on one durant
throws it down
it's a 77-4 rad
irving have combined for 40 points
durant is off back tapped on the slap
did what he gets
how low it goes irving scores
they're staying and watching the game
for you young kids out there play
against someone bigger all the time
someone
games i'm wondering not about how many
people
think that the lakers can win and after
this game tonight i know people are
going to be arguing saying did you see
kevin durant hit that shot from the top
of the key
game i'll do with you even the ones from
manhattan and other places lying
brooklyn